schläge tritte selbst kinder werden
verletzt es sind bilder die uns wirklich
sprachlos machen hier in einem freibad
in berlin steglitz massenschlägerei mit
rund 100 männer in einzelfall ein
problem bad in denen ja oder würden sie
am wochenende einfach wieder ins
schwimmbad gehen ins freibad gehen vor
allen dingen dieses freibad gehen da
muss es doch jetzt drunter und drüber
gehen neue sicherheitsvorkehrungen die
menschen alle dort sprechen über diese
gewalt sehen vom wochenende kira ortmann
bringen wir es einmal auf den stand was
sagen die menschen dort im freibad in
diesem sommer bad am insulaner und hat
man die sicherheitsvorkehrungen jetzt
drastisch erhöht
tatsächlich gibt es hier keine
erhöhungen der sicherheitsvorkehrungen
bisher zumindest noch nicht die menschen
die hier heute bisher das bad besucht
haben das waren vor allen dingen so ich
sag mal menschen zwischen 40 und 50 die
morgens sie ihre bahnen geschwommen
haben sich müssen sportlich betätigen
wollten bei dem schönen wetter dass er
heute hier wieder in berlin ist die
haben aber auch gesagt unter der woche
ist dann eh nicht so viel los aber die
erwarten auch dass es am wochenende eben
wieder mehr wird dann mehr menschen die
hierher kommen natürlich weil das wetter
auch wieder sehr gut sein soll und sie
erwarten dann aber auch von dem bad dass
das bad nicht so viele leute hier
einlässt denn das war tatsächlich etwas
was sie am wochenende sehr aufgefallen
ist das eben viel zu viele menschen rein
gelassen wurden und dann eben diese ja
dass es dann zu dieser schlägerei
gekommen ist ich habe mit tollen heute
morgen mit mehreren menschen gesprochen
hier da können wir einmal reinhören was
die so gesagt haben wir die sich gefühlt
haben hierher zu kommen
also ich finde das ganz furchtbar dass
man jetzt angst haben muss ins freibad
zu gehen
peinlich dass menschen so sind und
reagieren wir haben halt gedacht womit
das wird nicht so viel los sein und
nachmittags hätten was jetzt glaub ich
nicht gemacht wir haben ein enkel der
ist neun jahre und mit dem würde ich
niemals im moment hierher gehen also ich
musste mir das selber zu aber nicht ein
kind weil ich angst hätte dass er mitten
in der in der keilerei oder was immer
das war ist sich befindet ich eben nicht
helfen kann und auch keinem anderen kind
helfen kann was da ein gerät ich glaube
schon berliner problem also so viele
kulturen nationalitäten die dann
aufeinanderprallen und halt auch corona
zwei jahre eingesperrt also irgendwas
eskaliert ich weiß nicht woran das liegt
auf jeden fall
krawall bereite leute die das gemacht
haben und also ich würde auf jeden fall
am wochenende das schwimmbad meiden
wollen jetzt
ja und in ganz berlin schaut man jetzt
natürlich darauf wie es hier am
wochenende aussieht wie auch die anderen
schwimmbäder darauf reagieren ob sie
eben weniger menschen dann wirklich in
die schwimmbäder lassen ob sie
vielleicht auch erst gucken mit was für
einer oder mit was für einer laune die
leute vielleicht auch herkommen ob sie
schon den wie gewaltbereit sind oder
nicht da werden jetzt am wochenende
natürlich auch ein genaues auge drauf
werfen ganz genau keller vor allen
dingen nicht nur wie viele leute man
rein lässt und welche leute danke für
deinen report dort vom insulaner von dem
ja gewalt freibad hier in berlin der
harmlose anlass ein bespritzen mit
wasser bistro das ergebnis rund 100
personen schlagen aufeinander ein
mehrere verletzte und ein polizei
großeinsatz
wird die polizei am montag mitteilt
kommt es am sonntagnachmittag zu einer
massenschlägerei in einem sommerbad im
berliner bezirk steglitz demnach sollen
sich gegen 16 uhr 25 zunächst zwei
gruppen bestehend aus vier und zehn
personen im spaß mit wasserpistolen
bespritzt haben allerdings entwickelt
sich aus dem anfänglichen spaß erst eine
verbale und dann eine körperliche
auseinandersetzung
es war eine tolle ausgelassene stimmung
und plötzlich bildete sich halt ein
großer pulk aber ich muss auch sagen der
sicherheit ziehen zwar sehr schnell vor
ort und es kam halt zur
auseinandersetzung zu rangeleien als
sicherheitskräfte schlichten wollen
eskaliert die situation am ende sind an
der massenschlägerei rund 100 leute
beteiligt alles festgehalten in mehreren
videos die person die ich erzähle im
moment haben keinen respekt mehr vor
leuten und wenn ich dann auch noch zum
ausdruck welche vorwiegend leute mit
migrationshintergrund sehe also auch
verschiedene kulturelle neben dann muss
ich sagen das kann somit weiter geht der
horror vor allem für familien die mit
ihren kindern den heißen sonntag mit
spaß im freibad verbringen wollen als
die schlägerei zwischen den rund 100
jungen männern ausbricht stehen kinder
im pulk im hintergrund sieht man wie
mütter aufspringen ihre kinder in
sicherheit bringen also ich hätte keine
lust mit meiner familie mich in einem
solchen freibad zu befinden wo ein
solches chaos
ist es vielleicht abbild auch was in der
gesellschaft sich an entwicklung an der
einen oder anderen stelle zeigen
ermittlungen vor ort führen zunächst zu
vier tatverdächtigen im alter von 23
zweimal 21 und 15 jahren
gegen die vier wird nun wegen besonders
schweren landfriedensbruchs ermittelt
gegen einen 21 jährigen wird zudem wegen
gefährlicher körperverletzung ermittelt
er soll auf einen sicherheits
mitarbeiter des schwimmbades
eingeschlagen haben ein zehnjähriger
junge der in die aggressive gruppe
geriet bekam einen faustschlag gegen den
kopf ab
[Musik]
herr bilder die uns nicht loslassen
bilder über die wir sprechen müssen und
das machen wir mit cdu urgestein
wolfgang bosbach schönen guten tag ihnen
was ging nicht wussten was ging ihnen
durch den kopf was ging ihnen auch
durchs herz welche gefühle hatten sie es
sieht diese bilder gesehen haben ja
sofort zwei gedanken der erste gedanke
das ist nicht das erste mal und ich
fürchte es wird auch nicht das letzte
mal sein und der zweite gedanke was
machen eigentlich familien mit ihren
kindern die überlegen gehen wir an
schönen an heißen tagen ins freibad ja
oder nein oder lassen wir es lieber
bleiben weil die gefahr als gar nicht
unmittelbar beteiligter geschädigt zu
werden sehr hoch ist mir würde es sehr
leid tun aber ich hätte verständnis
dafür wenn familien insbesondere eltern
von kleinen kindern sagen würden da
gehst du jetzt mal nicht hin und ganz
konkret wie würden sie die frage für
sich beantworten also ich habe mir die
ganz persönlich gestellt das ist das
freibad bei mir in der nähe das ist das
nächste in das ich mit meinen kindern
gehen würde wie würden sie die frage für
sich beantworten für sie mit ihren
kindern mit ihren enkeln ja gut also
beide kinder aus dem gröbsten raus wie
es so schön heißt aber mit einem baby
würde ich da nicht hingehen jedenfalls
würde ich das freibad sofort verlassen
wenn ich sehe achtung erbrechen tumulte
aus es nutzt ja nicht viel wenn man sich
komplett aus allem heraus hält wenn man
einbezogen wird in gewalttaten mit denen
man weder etwas zu tun hat noch zu tun
haben möchte man sieht ja auch in dem
video die mütter wir wissen nicht was
sie rufen aber wir sind uns ziemlich
sicher dass es um den schutz ihrer
kinder geht
absoluter horror vorstellung und werden
auch julia klöckner gehört die sagte sie
würde nicht in so ein bad gehen und
vielleicht sagt er sie ist das auch in
gewissem sinne abbild unserer
gesellschaft wasser gerade passiert wie
sehen sie das was passiert da gerade
warum passiert das
weil wir eine unbegreifliche
gewaltbereitschaft haben weil die
offensichtlich jungen männer um die es
hier geht in verhältnissen groß geworden
sind wo konflikte wo auseinandersetzung
nicht friedlich mit worten gelöst werden
sondern mit gewalt und dann eskaliert
etwas sehr sehr schnell ein wort gibt
das andere ein faustschlag gibt den
anderen und dann hat man solche
tumultartigen szenen ich möchte das
jetzt nicht unmittelbar vergleichen weil
es auch signifikante unterschiede gibt
aber das prinzip ist das gleiche sie
berühmte kölner silvester nach 2015 2016
gattin schon jahre davor in einem
freibad in duisburg ähnliche
auseinandersetzungen das müsste so 2009
2010 gewesen sein weil es viele
schlechte nicht so viele gewaltbereite
junge männer gibt die sagen das ist mein
revier bestimme ich die regeln und
machen wir uns bitte nichts vor das ist
aufgabe der betreiber eines freibades
für sicherheit der gäste zu sorgen aber
da muss man ja mit einer hundertschaft
antreten um sich der respekt verschafft
uns anhören das will er aber gar nicht
leisten können in der tat wir haben
gestern die ganzen tag hier schon
darüber diskutiert was kann man dagegen
tun und es kamen ganz viele vorschläge
ich fand irgendwie nichts was richtig
greifbar war und wo wir danach hier
standen und gesagt haben okay das könnte
helfen dann kam rainer wendt und hat
gesagt gesichts kontrollen im eingang
aber ganz ehrlich wir sehen ja auf den
bildern das sind hunderte und wie soll
ich am gesicht erkennen dass der sich
anschließend bereit ist zu prügeln also
wie würden sie das lösen an so einem
sommertag zum beispiel in berliner oder
bei ihnen im bergisch gladbach am
freibad wen würden sie da rein lassen
wen nicht ins freibad
sie müssen jeden rein lassen der die
eintritts voraussetzung erfüllt der
eintritt bezahlt und decke ein
hausverbot hat ich kenne nicht die zahl
der freibäder in berlin ich kenne sie
meiner heimatstadt bergisch gladbach das
sind drei große freibäder relativ viel
für eine stadt mit 100.000 einwohner ich
nehme an in berlin dürfte es zehnmal so
viel sein dann kommen noch die bubble
sehen wie wannsee noch dazu ich weiß
jetzt nicht was eine gesichts kontrolle
bringen könnte außer der beantwortung
der frage versucht hier jemand rein zu
kommen der aus verbot hat das ist ja
dann die schranke auf die rechtliche
hürde aber
sie können hier man dann doch nicht an
der nasenspitze an gehen ob er mit
latente gewaltbereitschaft
sei es zu einer veranstaltung anderer
art oder sei es ins freibad geht das
sehen das sehen sie doch keine man sie
können doch niemand dem eintritt
verwehren mit der begründung oyo junger
mann das scheint es aber latent
gefährlich zu sein sie lasse ich hier
nicht rein das geht nicht